and now the giants again the only bad
news is they got to go back and play on
that
that field that they really would rather
not play on but uh the nfl not giving
them any relief and the giants position
is everything's fine
and i i i i i well i just
you know the nflpa has said they support
the 49ers in this it's just what can you
really do in a
press time frame it's not like you're
going to rip up the turf and put down
new turf
and you know there are other stadiums
you could move the game to now
the bills play at home and you know you
don't want to have everyone travel an
extended
uh distance but and then there's the
issue with traveling
parties going from one state to another
with the pandemic
that none of that's been discussed none
of that's even been mentioned it's never
even been whispered
and we're three days from the game
they're have they got to play on that
that turf
whether they like it or not chris and
it's going to be a challenge for kyle to
get
those guys to not think about it because
i think that's the problem whether
there's an issue with it or not
if you think there is it's something
else you're carrying around as baggage
in your brain
that you've got to process with
everything else yeah that's exactly what
it is as a football player
when you see your you know fellow
teammates
down in agony and oh
man the look in their eye of like they
know the season's over right there
you know that's that's the crap that
scares you a football player football
players who are scared about
nothing in life just about that's the
crap that sticks in their brain
throughout the week and you have that
like just
burned image like of oh i could see nick
bosa on the ground and the look in his
eye
and that that scares the death out of a
competitor or a guy who makes his living
you know playing sports
so when you see and then you see that
many guys go down
and that many difference makers yeah
it's going to be in their head you know
maybe they wear different cleats this
week
i will say this and i said it yesterday
you know first off
how much money does the nfl waste every
year on
players who end up not being able to
play
because they get hurt for reasons you
know why do we even have field turf
still in the nfl okay that's the one
thing
injuries are 30 greater on turf i i
don't understand that so that's the
first thing i just want to argue the
other thing too
like i said yes what would be other
alternative grow grass i mean the
problem is
grass doesn't grow as well how did we
make it through 100 years of football to
this point without you know i don't know
how we did it without field turf it's
just i'm not sure how we got here
well chris chris you got to admit the
field turf
was at least is at least a slight
upgrade
over the green cement that your dad
played on he played on astro turf he
played on worse
like worse that's my point right at
least this is better than that well it
is better than that but how about just
go to grass
like the good old-fashioned earth god
stuff
grass yeah i mean i just i don't get
that
you know we've had this conversation
before guys in la liga
ronaldo's and the messi's of the world
and the premiership
they don't it's in their contract if we
go to field turf
i don't play the game i mean that's what
happens they come over here to america
and they don't play because they go oh
it's a football stadium
with field turf i don't play on this but
back to my
my point here with this too is the one
thing i noticed all right
and again i've been on a lot of fields
and seen a lot of fields and i
actually even talked to somebody with
the jets yesterday about this
and this is i i i asked him because i
noticed it on
watching the last two weeks of giants
games there
there's not enough black pebbles on the
field too that would be the thing that
jumped out to me right you see those
black rubber pebbles
it does not look like there's a lot of
them and that would be that was what i
was told
those are toxic by the way those are
toxic yeah
well not to happen i mean that's another
issue your ligaments but yeah
but that was the one thing i was told by
somebody with the jets too he goes the
turf's new
it's good he goes if there's one
complaint he goes there's not enough of
those pebbles he goes it's it's very
grabby
and it is it looks grabby and you saw
that last week with some of the guys
knees
you know what those pebbles are don't
you rubber i just figured it was rubber
they're ground up tires tires yeah
that's what they are
yes yeah trent williams addressed this
issue yesterday he said i'd be lying to
tell you we're not going to be thinking
about it
or it's not going to be across our minds
but when you've got 300-pound linemen in
front of you
that's trying to put you on your back i
think the surface falls on the back
burner but he did say
it's sticky thick and spongy sticky said
it's tricky
it's tricky to uh maneuver on but isn't
it odd that the giants are saying
we've practiced on at all of training
camp we've got no problem with it at all
i mean is that a certain amount of jedi
mind trick
or are they truly fine with it i mean if
they had a problem with it we'd heard
something yeah you're right
yeah you're right we would have heard
something you're right i i think
even the players despite maybe the i'm
going into their own stadium i think
they would have spoke out too
you're right i'm so so it can't be that
crucial because we didn't even really
he'll just hear the steelers complain
about it
either but that's the word it looked
like to me you know the nfl language
would be sticky
grabby those type of things big guys
don't like to play on this surface no
matter what
um but yeah that's just the way it
looked even with bose's injury
you know yeah he had somebody push him
and everything but there was no
give in the turf at all so what gave his
leg
unfortunately and um it's going to be in
the brains of the 49ers players
hopefully they can overcome it
maybe you wear different shoes this week
maybe you don't wear real cleats
you wear those turf shoes that just have
little nubs on them
those were things that i would be
thinking about as a player right now to
go
maybe let me see if like let me practice
today with these what do these feel like
and just start you know experimenting to
what makes you feel the best
i do agree with the broader point you
made though for the investment that's
made in the various players on the field
right you would think that the league
and the individual owners
would want to protect their investments
yes better
and i'm no botanist i've just always
been under the impression that in some
of these northeastern climates you can't
get grass to the point where it needs to
be
all year long but i will say this they
pull it off in wisconsin
thank you and pittsburgh pull it off in
wisconsin
well you have a college team that plays
there that ruins it well
they play high school and they play high
school games there it's overused
right and it's a lot better than it was
in 2007 on the monday night game when
the
the punt actually stuck on the ground
because it was so wet it was a mess
remember mike tarico on the call of that
one the ball that just went
into the grass and did not bounce that
was a forgettable night but
but yeah i i if they really wanted to do
it
they could do it it's just like pete
carroll wearing a mask there's a way to
do it
and something is better than nothing and
maybe anything is better than artificial
surfaces but we've just accepted over
the years that
this is the way it is and again it's
still better than the stuff your dad
played on i don't know how the hell they
played i don't know either
at old giant stadium and veterans three
rivers stadiums
and insane it's it's a horrendous
horrendous anybody that's ever tried to
run on that good good luck getting out
of bed the next day
even if no one hits you it is horrendous
on the joints
there is no give none and uh so but they
can always do better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports